[Music]
man let me tell you something okay look
here's the thing man dude this story
like i'm learning this about donnie
kate's man donnie kate's dude this guy
is an amazing writer but his stories
never pick up until you get to issue
number three and man
okay dude the ending of this story is
crazy it's one of the best endings to
authorize not even any to a thor story
it's one of the best endings to a thor
comic ever alright so so okay look
here's the thing here's the thing check
this out so this story opens up right
and it says for over 4 billion years
earth's sun has burned the hearts of
countless evils to cinders and bones and
atoms but along the way the light has
been infected the well poisoned and now
a new evil grows in the furnace of
midgard slowly evolving growing stronger
every day waiting waiting for destiny to
arrive and it says of this ancient evil
spreading reaching out from the flames
of the untold destruction it will bring
upon the universe the total and complete
extinction it will herald that story is
not ready to be told
yet but there is only so much darkness
one can throw into a star before the
star turns black and what is forged in
those flames will carry that darkness
right so what this does is it basically
picks back up with the last conflict
that we had right the last battle that
we had we're literally thor's fighting
his hammer right remember for those of
you guys who are just joining us here in
case you just clicked on this for the
very first time that thor had basically
not really lost the ability to wield his
hammer it had turned into this thing
where everybody could wield the hammer
of thor whenever they wanted to now
that's not a new thing and depending on
what thor fans you're talking to some
people will just kind of be like really
but the way the donnie cates does this
is amazing right the kicker here is that
thor didn't know what was going on but
then suddenly the hammer was basically
going around the nine realms right
yottenheim and like muskelheim just all
these different realms even to like
broxton oklahoma on earth where thor had
initially brought back asgard back
during the days of post civil war and it
basically just started killing all these
different people and so we didn't know
why thor's hammer had an effect turned
evil and of course it basically turned
out that thor's hammer was now a
sentient being now the reason for that
is because the entire basis right the
power of thor's hammer is rooted in what
was called the mother storm basically at
some previous point in time odin had
captured a cosmic entity and placed it
inside the hammer replaced it in a piece
of uru metal that was forged into the
hammer so quite literally thor has been
channeling the power of a cosmic entity
whenever he was wielding his hammer and
this made perfect sense because it
answered the question how it is that
despite how capable thor is the hammer
always seemed to allow him to overcome
forces that were often times more
powerful than he was right like
juggernaut juggernaut's a perfect
example juggernaut is powered by an
elder god whose power dwarfs most all
magical beings out there with the
exception of maybe like cathone and like
zom and like that's it
[Music]
that's really it right like the power of
sidorak is insane and is way beyond the
power of thor yet somehow he was always
able to hold his own against juggernaut
and even defeat him using the power the
power of mjolnir except for the old
stories when juggernaut had a force
field and then mjolnir didn't work on
him somebody's definitely going to say
that so i'm going to beat you to the
punch but the thing about this is it's
it's a crazy thing because in this
moment obviously the god of hammers is
now the wielder of the hammer itself and
thor himself cannot overcome the power
of the god of hammers so in effect he
can't control his old hammer he is just
as subservient to his power as anybody
else so when the hammer's thrown at him
and it lands on top of him and he's
basically being pushed down into the mud
and faces the possibility of drowning
there's nothing he can do to stop it and
even with the the god of hammers itself
there's nothing he can do to stop this
thing and so ultimately the questions
asked by thor because remember thor
doesn't know the story of the hammer he
doesn't know that odin basically locked
a cosmic entity inside this hammer he
doesn't know any of that all he knows is
just like the hammer was something that
he couldn't lift when he was younger
because of the enchantment of odin and
then eventually he was able to pick it
up because he was worthy and like that's
basically it what donnie kate's does
here man he turns the entire thing on
his head and it's amazing right so thor
asked the question right he says who are
you what kind of trick is this how are
you doing this and ultimately the hammer
says thor you wound me right you and i
have been together for so long well
except for that brief dalliance that i
had with jane foster which pissed off a
bunch of fans of the thor community
although i loved the jane foster story
and so the hammer says like you of all
people should know about sowing one's
wild oats right and the hammers is kind
of like call it a phase right i just
wanted to try something a little bit
different now where that almost seems
like a kind of offhanded remark the
hammer kind of poking fun at thor
there's actually a basis behind this
right which is so crazy because thor
asked the question like you don't know
anything about me and where thor gets
ready to like go on this rant right but
if you want to learn like let me up and
i will show you and so on and so forth
and and the the god of hammers like no
you know i'm done like i'm tired of
hearing your speeches and says that's
ultimately what this all comes down to
right speeches titles crowns thrones
parliaments and senate meetings and blah
blah blah i'm just afraid i've grown so
bored of it all here's the kicking of
this right here's a caveat to this if
you know when that that that story was
told to us when we were given this
revelation that odin had trapped a
cosmic entity inside the hammer and
that's the basis behind his power we had
to know something like this was coming
eventually right something like this
would have to take place a sentient
living thinking thing trapped inside of
a metal artifact trapped inside of a
weapon would at some point desire to
break free and that was one of the
things that was kind of established here
right it was sort of unofficially
explained over the course of like jason
aaron's run and like donnie kate's run
and even if you look if you take this
information and this really gives you
credence to how how hardcore and how
intensely donnie case was looking at
thor you look back at the old walt
simonson run from way back in the day
right from like 70s 80s and whatnot you
basically get this point where you're
just kind of like okay so the only
reason thor was ever able to wield this
hammer is because the hammer allowed it
the hammer allowed him to lift the
hammer that it had nothing to do with
odin's enchantment and so it's kind of
cool because thor of course summons the
lightning and then having his little
portion of the odin force because
remember thor has the odin force in him
odin is currently like he's he's not the
all father anymore and so ultimately
thor ends up channeling the lightning
and creating like a lightning based
sword which is amazing but it's just
this it's just this ridiculously cool
thing but in the end like when he goes
to face this hammer like the hammer's
just kind of like do you never learn
right like have you never learned
anything thor the god of thunder you
should really know better no one can
outrun the lightning and so when thor
goes to lodge a punch against the the
god of hammers the god of hammers sticks
up the hammer and thor shatters his arm
like literally cannot break through his
own hammer and then at that point right
the god of hammers is like and there is
nothing mjolnir cannot break this it's
just one of the cruelest moments ever
and so that's when like the god of
hammers starts to spill these beans
right and when thor's totally shocked
the god of hammers is like i know more
than almost anyone i know how this must
feel i have been there thor odin's son
at your side in your hand every single
time you have beaten back another
gathering storm of death i have watched
for eons i know all of your deeds even
those that you've forgotten all of your
triumphs all of your secrets all of your
weaknesses and yes thor you can be
broken you simply just have to know how
and so at that point you get this really
amazing moment where like odin steps in
now here's the thing to understand this
is a big deal in years past this is
something odin almost never would have
done odin would have just been like this
is your responsibility thor right you're
the all father you do your thing and
that's kind of the crazy thing odin has
almost always been callous whenever it
came to his his involvement with thor
he's almost kind of been i mean he
treated him like a like a father treats
a son to a degree but there was always
this barrier there was always this thing
where odin was never the guy who would
read thor like a bedtime story or
anything like that right he wouldn't
really raise his son in the way that we
as people here would raise our sons
right when you are a father raising your
son there's a bond there that just can
never really be broken in a healthy
father-son relationship there is an
incredibly unique bond there when you're
little kids the roles are reversed right
the sons are closer to the mothers the
daughters are closer to the fathers but
as time progresses and the suns need to
learn how to become a man become a
healthy productive man that can give
back to the world they look to their
father to be that source of guidance and
that's where that bond forms and to a
degree that was the case between thor
and odin it was the case that thor would
often look to odin for some measure of
guidance but the kind of guidance auto
would provide would be like don't
disappoint me boy like it was that kind
of a thing but very a very harsh kind of
guidance right not very much a spiritual
god in that capacity right odin was
always incredibly hard on his son and so
to see him step in here like this save
his life and then say like let's end
this damn thing shall we that when the
hammer thinks that that odin is talking
to thor the response of of odin is no
i'm not talking to you right saving my
son's life obviously but i'm not
referencing you that what odin was doing
was working directly with seth now
remember sif is basically replaced
heimdall she's the one that controls the
bifrost and she's the one who sees
everything so quite literally what they
end up doing is basically teleporting uh
the god of hammers to a place beyond
creation now here's the thing and that's
what's so crazy about this this is an
entirely new concept created by donnie
cates this is something that we've never
seen before and we've seen different
depictions of places that go like far
beyond anything we've ever seen so like
a really good example of this there's a
really two good examples that have been
used recently the first one is what's
called the realms beyond and that's
basically where heimdall was taken when
he essentially died but the realms
beyond is just the white hot room right
the white hot room is in effect the
afterlife right the realm of mistress
death that's why after that introduction
right the idea of like the realms beyond
and the establishing point of heimdall
going to the white hot room is basically
his afterlife that in effect mistress
death is actually more of an avatar of
the phoenix force than the other way
around right the phoenix force is like
this omniversal kind of energy source
that exists out there that in every
universe has its own quote-unquote
personal avatar but there are some
avatars that stand above all the others
in the sense that they're referred to as
what's called the white phoenix of the
crown that's what jean grey was but the
fact that like the home base where jean
grey operates where she is at her full
totality in terms of being able to
manifest 100 percent of the phoenix
forces power is quite literally the
afterlife the realm of mistress death
that a lot of people hit at this as
essentially being death is more of a of
an aspect of the phoenix force instead
of the other way around this is actually
compounded by the old chris claremont
stories when jean grey with the phoenix
force met the realm of death it was
actually explained how it is the realm
of death works and its role with the
white hot room but the other part of
this in marvel comics is during alley
ewing's ultimates we were introduced to
something called the far shore right the
furthest point of life and death where
basically all life kind of the edge of
where it exists this itself is far
beyond that right if the far shore we're
talking about is in effect the realm of
like the one below all or anything along
those lines this is way beyond that and
in fact that's what we're told here that
odin basically says sif just sent that
thing beyond the farthest point of known
existence and endless abyss beyond the
eyes of even the most ancient abstract
primordial gods right it's beyond the
cosmic entities now it's kind of crazy
the question you kind of have to ask
here is like how did odin even know
about this place in the first place but
this looks like it's a place beyond the
multiverse now am i saying that it's
beyond verse no because i imagine
somebody's gonna be like the beyonders
are coming back no i mean there's
nothing to indicate that's the case
it'd be dope if it was but nonetheless
right this is just the furthest point of
existence right where basically you know
once you get past this point nothing
exists right everything ceases to be if
this is truly the case the only person
we know of who has ever been in this
particular location right the place
beyond this furthest point of existence
was thanos right literally if you guys
remember at the beginning of all new all
different marvel thanos basically
emerged from a realm of nothingness
right like he was literally trapped out
there where nothing existed because
remember thanos was banned from the
realm of mistress death he's immortal
and he cannot die and so because of that
like he couldn't go to the afterlife so
he was literally at least essentially it
seems like he was beyond even this point
right this furthest point of existence
so we have no idea what this realm is it
looks like sauron's there we have no
clue how this works but regardless
ultimately thor asked the question of
odin what is happening like what is
going on here this thing said that it
was mjolnir brought to life and that's
when odin finally reveals the truth to
thor and says that mjolnir has always
been alive son he says i trapped the
mother storm inside of it eons ago and
when the dwarves forged that cursed rock
into mjolnir they told me those who died
making it that their voices their souls
live on in the hammer itself i never
believed it was true but whatever it is
whatever has taken hold of that hammer
and ultimately you never really get an
explanation there instead what's
essentially happened here is the god of
storms has made its way back immediately
like it immediately gets right back here
again so that's the level of power that
we're talking about and even odin is
flabbergasted he's like no that's not
possible there's no way this thing could
just come back here but where it's
channeling itself directly at thor then
ultimately odin pushes his son out of
the way to save his life and odin is hit
by the hammer and basically crippled in
the process and that's when that's man
that's when you get this revelation
i'm sorry i'm so excited people but it
is dope oh my god it's so dope so this
hammer pops back up right and this
hammer says it hurts doesn't it right to
lose to be left alone and when the
question's asked by thor why why are you
doing this you get this amazing exchange
between the two this amazing monologue
that the hammer says you take me for
granted you always have but you none of
you ever understood me you thought my
enchantment meant you must be a worthy
warrior to be noble or true of heart but
ask yourself thor does any of that
describe you are you a noble person are
you true of heart are you an inherent
good guy no thor you're a dick you kill
people all the time any any all these
enemies out there you kill them on a
regular basis and and like as soon as i
read that i was like damn son she's
right okay this is a really good example
during the secret empire event one of
the things that happened is people were
mad because stephen right evil captain
america could lift the hammer of thor
and one of the arguments was like he's a
villain he's killing people all that
kind of stuff and then like in hindsight
looking at that it's like is thor really
any different thor like literally just
goes on these crusades killing people
that he has personally deemed as enemies
like literally thor is like i am a good
guy i know that because i have decided
that like that was basically thor like
in his early days before he joined the
avengers like he just relished in
conflict in war and death and
destruction and so the hammer says no no
i am a hammer to be worthy of me is to
break to smash to destroy thor because
that's what hammers do and you with your
throne and your crown and your speeches
well this isn't the first time i've
grown tired of you isn't it and that's
when thor is just kind of like jane
foster right that's when he realizes why
it is the hammer switched to jane and
the hammer says yes jane threw me into
the sun and you left me broken you left
me to burn but you see i was not alone
in the sun you guys remember jason those
of you guys remember jason aaron's run
you know what's coming son you know it's
coming son so this is like i wasn't
alone in the sun there was something
else there something powerful and we
burned together and then we were remade
as one its spirit became entangled with
mine its soul inside of me thor picks up
like that and he's like oh dear god no
he's like no
the worst possible situation
absolutely okay so it says this is and i
awoke with a voice with the rage of a
billion billion beings with the rage
with the rage son of the man god with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an
man i'm sorry i'm so excited people it's
just really it's a it's an amazing
ending to this comic i can't wait man i
can't wait until we get to the next
issue god is so ridiculously good thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace